سمارت اني لابس فلور اني لابسه
[تصفيق]
الوحش الذي صنعه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب وفق وصف الاعلام الامريكي قد يصارعه
على عرينه لامتلاكه الصفات نفسها ممزوجه
بالانضباط والابتعاد عن الفضاء
وهو حاكم فلوريدا منذ عام 2019 ومرشح
للمنصب نفسه مجددا بيكا
السياسيه المستقبليه اي انه لم يؤكد او
ينفي نيه الترشح للرئاسه لكن اسمه اوقيما
في دائره المنافسين المحتملين الترامب اذا
قرر الاخيره حوض سباق الرئاسه بعد عامين
على اعتبار انه يعمل في ازقه السلطه
الخلفيه التي كانت من اختصاص ترامب ويضع
في جعبته نقاطه تفوق تتمثل بتكاته الاكثر
دقه فهو لا يضرب خصومه بمراكز ضعفهم او
يستخدم صفاته
تهديدا كبيرا للرئيس السابق ويمتلك فرصا
متعدده للوصول للبيت الابيض تتمثل اولا
بصغر سنه وقد سجل تق بنسب ضئيله على ترامب
في ولايات مثل يوهان في ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري للرئاسه عام 2024
الحاكم الجمهوري الذي بدا مسيرته السياسيه
قبل عشر سنوات بنيله مقعدا بمجلس النواب
عرف بسياساته المناهضه للقيود المشدده
التي فرضتها رائحه كورونا وكان الاسرع
بتنفيذ رغبه ترامب باعاده فتح الاقتصاد
ووقفه مشابهه في الدعم غير المحدود
لاسرائيل ورفض الاتفاق مع ايران والتشدد
مع الصين ديسانتس قد يكون نسخه محدثه واقل
حده من الرئيس السابق لكن وفق صحف امريكيه
فامتعه ترامب وما تشمله من طريقه اثاره
انصاره الى لا مبالاته تجاه خصومه
السياسيين ووسائل الاعلام والارتجال
والنرجسيه عده ليس هناك ترامب من دونها